and we talked last time about the
scientology stuff and i know you're so
open
and so brave because people would think
you know you get lamb bass suit and
people say oh it's this and it's this
but you stick to your guns this is what
i believe like the raw milk like
whatever
i live a happy existence i'm happy i'm
not judging you why should you judge me
and
you do that and you know i wonder
sometimes like because you're such a
brilliant actress and you've done so
much great work do you think it ever
hinders you from getting roles because
some people are like oh she's a
scientologist we're not hiring her do
you think that happens
i have no idea i have no idea i mean
that would be
that would be wild to me because i don't
know exactly what they would
think i mean it's like it's like
this ephemeral idea that like there's
badness there like it's
it's a trendy thing to just be like
dismissive about it
but other than that like if you truly
have an issue like i don't know
i don't know that's weird well you know
i have a friend uh
my friend john heater i've talked about
this he's a mormon yeah he doesn't sit
there and
preach mormonology to me or mormonism or
whatever he doesn't
you know i love you know they say that
religion
um some people will say religion
organized religion
is really is a terrible thing some
people will say it's the only thing
right this is the divisiveness
and there shouldn't be because if it
works for you
and you're not telling other people what
to do and how to live their lives
that is a success story when it comes to
religion i have a friend in indiana
who is a christian boy and they go to
church and they
love the lord and that's what they do
and my friend john they go to church
and they have four kids and he's
incredibly family oriented and nothing
really
like uh business-wise uh industry-wise
faze him and he's able to have a really
happy existence
and he's a mormon and this is what he
believes and people will get the
the thing the fundamentalists like well
aren't you a polygamist
he's like no that's what gave us a bad
name those are people that like
that's not us that's like i think it's
the fundamentalist but so are there
you know some people will give you know
all of a sudden one thing will happen
with a scientologist something
bad will happen they'll get accused of
something and it's terrible and then all
of a sudden it brings down the whole
the whole thing yeah and i think that's
like a that's a
symptom of just not knowing
anything about scientology in general
which they've tried to
solve by starting their own television
network so like
let us show you who we are this is what
we believe this is come look at our
churches this is these are the people
that are
doing scientology like there's so much
information just trying to get out there
about like
you don't know anything about us so if
somebody like makes a snide joke or
makes some crazy accusation or whatever
then that's all you know
so it's like getting getting some more
information out there which
i don't know if anybody's taking
advantage of i don't know if anybody's
watching that
what's the show called what's the show
it's an entire
network called the scientology network
that has shows
on all day so look in a nutshell someone
says okay what is it exactly what would
you say
in a sentence or two scientology is an
applied
religious philosophy applied because you
do it you don't just it's not just a
faith religious because it's addressing
you as a spiritual being
and philosophy because it is all of the
questions of life
and why are we here and who are we and
what potentials do we have and how do we
reach them and
what is the purpose of life which is by
the way to help
to help you know to be part of the
entire like
ecosystem of the planet and spiritually
to just to like to be of service as
somebody might say
sounds pretty good that's it but like in
in a nutshell those words applied
religious philosophy
and believing that um
the man is basically good
not that man is basically bad
it's hard it's hard to believe that wait
lately isn't it
it's kind of hard to believe that in
general uh that you know because
you know for you know whether whatever
you believe out there you know whether
you're a jew or a scientologist or a
mormon or whatever
you know catholic christian hindu we can
go on
um sometimes you think well if there is
a god
maybe this is his plan to kind of say
hey [ __ ] sticks
why don't you wake up you're destroying
this [ __ ] planet you're
you're killing each other you're
terrible to each other you're you know
and so it's like sort of like a wake-up
call and i think that you know you hope
at the end of this pandemic you hope
people just go
god it's so much easier being nice to
people
isn't that the truth i mean
you